he got banned because he was empowering  people to be better in order to keep  people inside the Matrix they need to be  dependent how do we make people  dependent will we make them weak we make  them poor you know I think the nine to  five doesn't work anymore I think it's  one of the most dangerous things you can  have having one form of income is just  your one step away from poverty in my  opinion right and so Andrew was waking  people up you know I speak to a lot of  young guys love him so much because he's  telling them it's okay what you're  feeling it's okay to be angry it's okay  to be competitive he's teaching them how  to make money online how to basically  become independent let's be clear they  didn't ban him because of his so-called  misogyny you have porn online you have  terrorists online Balenciaga I don't  know if you saw that I didn't know who  they were they have an advert campaign  dedicated to kiddie porn Bella Hadid  promoting kiddie porn that's all okay